pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
clara devons êtes là déclaré abbas
rien n'indique
ne vous avais pas entendu après je sois
là s'arrête dans la cour eh bien vous
n'êtes pas en avant ce matin trompe vie
dont ce dimanche 1-1 comme la veine que
je me dérange
vous pouvez au prix qu'ils vous paye pas
des américains
manquerait plus que ça vous n'êtes
jamais content alors ouais enfin de tous
leurs droits pas la maison et là comme
ça au moins vous êtes nourrir je touche
à rien pourquoi parce que je suis
français soit madame bof j'ai été élevée
aux bifteck et aux pommes frites pas la
boîte de conserve
comment voulez vous qu'on se comprenne
avec des gens qui peuvent pas devin il
boit pas de vin blanc qu'est ce que vous
dites là matérialise la vérité enfin
quand carrière c'est la première fois
que je vois une chose pareille et
pourtant j'en ai vu des places offre via
voulez-vous s'il faisait les choses
comme nous ils ne se seraient pas des
américains
le sachet des sauvages pour sa demande
qu'est ce qu'ils viennent faire voler
saint louis sous louer des appartements
préfère et je vous assure que la
concierge il n'oublie pas moi pour ma
part j'ai pas à m'en plaindre de
monsieur et madame williamson mal ont pu
remarquer bien mais je crois pas j'y
arriverai pas coutume et allez c'est pas
tout ça
j'adore faire cuire leur maïs toujours
une comme moi a dit tu es à servir dans
les grandes maisons et bon dimanche à la
pop vous tu m'aimes madame élise
lala lala mettez vous donc au moins 10
pour rendre service aux gens bien gilles
mais bientôt midi lève-toi attarde
on a pris un compte mail était temps
alors alors julie et ben tu te décides
haut
il vous reste fermée chez l'épicier je
penserais pas d'ailleurs
dépêche toi pourquoi je retape le lit
l'allongé un air de fête
dire que j'ai même pas un bouquet de
fleurs pour mettre sur un thème qui nous
embête tout va vouloir faire de la mise
en scène un dimanche comme les autres
pas du tout c'est l'anniversaire de
tapis et un anniversaire c'est une fête
de famille il n'arrive qu'une fois par
an
mais salah gas josiane et fletch déjà
dit l'année dernière elle a pensé l'âge
de souffler sur les bougies
bah tu penses comme j'aime être des
bougies siens pour tout le monde puisse
les compter elle est debout
allanon de plus josiane elle un an de
plus à ce que le temps passe vite quand
même un n'étant pas bétonner leur est
tout de même question ja se marier ce
petit 1 on remarque est encore jeune et
paient pas réponse mon argent mais là
bel et bien nous quand on s'est mariés
j'avais 18 ans elle en est loin alors
qu'est-ce que ça prouve
tu t'es marié trop trouve la tour auto
atteint la mémoire courte lune il était
temps que 18 des remous conduire devant
monsieur le maire
on va des jeux zito obiols bata
peut-être pas hésité mais tu as bien
réfléchi n'empêche que quand tu as mis
ta fille au monde tu étais déjà madame
buddy list mais la veille à l'aise que
je pouvait prévoir qui naîtra un mois
avant terme
enfin pour ma fille si tu perds mais
j'aimerais mieux que ça se passe en
trois mots elle se mariera à l'église
on replante et sans qu'on ait besoin de
se presser avec qui elle a eu trois
plaies aux jambes alors là je ne suis
pas saigner aux quatre veines pour
qu'elle épouse en importe à qui ouais
elle a son brevet les sténodactylo d'une
bande s'est pour la première venue et
ses 15 ans il lui a fallu sa chambre au
sixième mais oui mais qu est ce qu elle
avait déjà ses goûts alors aux marques
j'ai l'impression qu'elle commence déjà
à s'y plaire à peu moins dans son île
c'est normal tu te dis qu'il faut
qu'elle se marie bah il faut il faut
quand on leur a trouvé un 15 ans qui lui
convienne est jolie comme élève à je
pense qu'il sera le plus difficile à
messi jean tous les hommes chantôme sur
elle dans la rue alors tu parlais mais
comme par hasard les hommes qui se
retourne sur les femmes dans la rue ils
sont toujours mariés
jean y en a quand même trois ponts
demander sa main ml les a refusé sa
décourager les autres on dirait au toit
dont la france en parler tu finiras par
est responsable car est vieille fille
j'en étais sûr c'est bien mais nous a
manqué ce que veut elle gagne sa vie
elle est indépendante alors qu'il nous
dit qu'elle veut se marier jamais dit
moi je cherche ce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va pas je la connais notre josiane
du sel elle est nerveuse par le lui les
son père non on vous demande au
téléphone à l'alimentation générale
encore un homme a péri oui monsieur il
n'a pas de sens non pardi c'est encore
il y avait quelqu'un de malade ou
infogrames je dis pas les déranger le
monde toute la journée comme ça pourrait
en vie pour un oral exagère alors pas
trop on va à la pêche aujourd'hui on va
taquiner le bouchon n'est pas une
service hockey enfin au mur et oublié
mais presque rien néant matin en
attendant elle son côté le dessus du
panier je vous ai choisis tous les
rapports qu'elle va presser dans la mine
lapa bus on lève toi qu'est ce que tu
dis là encore les et fils et les filles
de l'as plainoise sienne deux chattes et
ben dis-donc division qu'elle nous fait
une vie impossible à vouloir maintenir
enfermés enfin enfin pouvoir dormir
tranquille
à droite il avait pris rendez vous avec
l'angora de la rue boutarel
son panier était déjà pu préparer qu'est
ce qu'elle va encore nous ramener au bas
des bâtards ça me fait quelque chose de
penser qu'elles courent avec n'importe
qui comme ça une si jolie chatte à brive
et si saïdi est obèse
hélas alors excusez-moi je passe par
votre loge mais ça me pose vraiment pas
sortir dans la rue pour me rendre à
l'alimentation j'ai fait on se téléphone
telle invention moitié tout mon déjeuner
sur le feu et comme par hasard mon mari
les parts à prendre avec des passes
alors des rues mule
son déjeuner sur le feu bah ça doit être
du jeu libyen à y en a vraiment qui se
complique pas la vie vient pour monsieur
raymond dit encore quelqu'un mais qu'est
ce qu'il faut pour ces gens là dimanche
il peut pas rester chez eux après les
siens madame veuve faisons pas trop
grave cela faire découvrir leur art est
parvenu bah oui ça fait du bien pas des
noms depuis le temps à venir citons la
dernière fois qu'il vient à paris pour
la noël déjà ben à châteauroux ça compte
double bon tu vas prendre quelque chose
bon ben c'est pas de refus merci
monsieur bonne josiane est pas là ce
dimanche matin
elle en profite pour faire sa chambre à
fond elle va descendre bientôt oui ça va
t elle mon gars
quelque chose en toi ici mon petit break
testera faire rentrer en usine non non
non non non il va me prendre avec lui
dans son garage il a garé un chef aussi
deux étages le sous sol et un atelier de
réparation au ballon je m'en diras tant
ils avaient arrive c'est au nom fin bat
pour ça oui
ils ont un joli pavillon à la campagne
il se prive de rien on parle il avait
raison parce que son argent celui qui
l'a gagnée maintien il a des enfants
comment ben non justement il veut mettre
au courant de la faire pour quand il va
se retirer alors que c'est comme qui
dirait le fils de la maison où toi t'es
pas dans un sens oui ah bah tu vas
rester déjeuner avec nous un voudrais
pas vous déranger loi quand y en a pour
trois y en a pour quatre mois alors je
dis pas non d'autant que ça sort une
bombe on est que j'ai toujours apprécié
la cuisine de madame veuve avait
aujourd'hui tu m'en diras des nouvelles
je vous ai déjà bien si les jeunes et la
pierre à top 10 dont c'est
l'anniversaire de josiane ont pas si
j'avais su je lui aurais acheté un petit
cadeau elle donne ton verre il avait
alors dû spacieux mais tout ce mois il a
toutes les qualités ce prix là c'est pas
comme toi j'ai lu
elle est aux affaires pour une fois
voilà attention à toi as tu as fini la
bouteille ibérique est ce que savait
dépendant fini la bouteille et ben ça
veut dire que tu vas te marier dans
l'année je dis pas non mais c'est à dire
mais je suis très en retard juste un
petit bonjour en passant sa demande de
la baisse
oui nous avons traversé pour faire et
nous sommes allés à notre dame ça nous a
fait une petite promenade tous les
marronniers du sport sont en fleurs ou
votre manteau ma petite maman chérie tu
apprendras chaud et froid mais on ne m'a
pas présenté ce jeune homme quoi madame
le faire vous connaissez pas lucien de
vue oui il me semble vous êtes finis
saint-louis monsieur bayrou et hoyaux sa
maman est couturière t2p qu'une bonjour
monsieur young est enchantée
mademoiselle mm le faite vous avez vu
l'air vous n'oubliez pas que vous avez
matinée les enfants
mais non bien qu'en vélum boeuf
d'ailleurs tendu cadence après midi où
des jeunes ont très légèrement à il faut
vous dire monsieur que ma fille fait
partie du corps de ballet du théâtre du
châtelet au or vous êtes danseuse
mademoiselle oui monsieur avant de
savoir lire et écrire j'étais déjà sur
pointes
ma fille a débuté potiron dans le prince
de madrid s'est très c'est gracieux à la
danse en tutu
évidemment artis un milieu de gamme pose
aussi au mariage et je vous assure que
dans une maison n'est pas vous empruntez
sur la scène et vous faites une sauce
béchamel ou ses filiales de vente et car
je ne veux pas un parti des vanneaux dit
maman chérie et que faty sauget leurs
hommes dans la vie je suis mécanicien
madame ça on vous dit que c'est un bon
métier à moi je revienne à la mécanique
vous invitez avec votre vent mots oui
madame
mais je vais bientôt m'établir c'est
très bien ça et c'est ça mais moi ce
qu'il vous faut
et bien jolie petite femme pour tenir
votre intérieur mais le suit quand il
conçoit pas sans peine pour retrouver
une à la madame le pen supporter votre
avis ça court pas les rues
des filles comme il faut j'ai oublié
pour inventer le livre que josiane avait
prêté un peu ça s'était très bien ça
nous a bien plu les histoires d'amour de
l'histoire de france
je raffole de tout ce qui est historique
mois au cinéma c'est la même chose mais
c'est toujours intéressé mon humeur
c'est comme un jour à troy savez déjà
tous sont élevés mais parker est
toujours la première à l'est
mais on peut dire que vous aimez bien
élever votre jeune fille cette chronique
est tout sauf les fentes et qui revient
encore j'ai tenue alliant culture les
conquois ainsi et pour la couture d'une
adresse elle se fait tout servi jeunes
et vieux le salam et bientôt débarquer
vous madame le faire c'est elle qui
rameute toutes les chaussettes de son
père aux craintes des chaussettes une
plus fort et on vous croit sur parole
madame veuve jill pour ta fille josiane
vous allez voir ses proies de la reprise
et du stockage
j'en étais sûr on se demande vraiment ce
que tu peux faire pour éviter chose et
moi moi c'est pareil madame veuve je
trouve des chaussettes nous ne savons
pas ce que c'est quant aux ménages pour
mai josiane mais c'est une maladie qui
guette elle boucle naturellement jamais
au docteur m'a josiane du si ces shows
besoin d'une finale j'invite comme le
pont neuf et vous savez qu'elle se
débrouille pas mal en ondes et pas
dépensière elle a déjà tout de suite
c'est konami et durs sont rosso à celui
qui aura la chance de l'épouser il fera
pas une mauvaise affaire
encore faut-il qu'elle trouve un garçon
qui lui plaisent
il monsieur au téléphone oui l abattre
est prise c'est le printemps
or ce printemps mais vous avez un autre
dans votre loge madame de forêt oui on
en vient on s'installe on fait au pied
bonjour mesdames toujours aux pennois
celle là et cette façon de fixer les
hommes mais c'est monsieur lucie meygal
enfin que vous avez pas vu dans le
quartier monsieur lucien aujourd'hui
vous avez toujours être un pétrole non
non maintenant j'ai une moto a eu une
moto mais alors vous allez m'emmener
tenir le coup
or elle renvoyait le coucou que l'on
tait mais la saison du boucau et fini ma
dame m'a dit vous irez l'année prochaine
avec votre nom c'est un vieux rabat-joie
les poissons avis en ce moment j'aime la
nature moi et je ne peux tout de même
pas y aller tout seul puisque monsieur
lucien propos si gentiment de me rendre
en coupe sur sa boîte dont ils vont
germaine est ce que tu te fout du monde
quoi qu est-ce qu il ya encore le
déjeuner c'est pour demain j'ai fait un
mois hier et c'est comme ça trois fois
par jour d'abord que d'un téléphone
quitte à téléphoner quelqu'un le nom
j'exige le nom pour ce type va ne pousse
pas en avant mais les vous de ce qui
vous regarde
c'est mon amant là tu es content et
badoit un vote facile vous taquine c'est
sa belle soeur qui m'a téléphoné et
lebouc je vous y reprenne
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur pape s'était créé
dans la poche on me dit oh mon dieu ou
photoblog si ça continue un qu'est ce
que c'est que cette rencontre de niveau
quel monde les pluies de la nuit
ces quais pour les voisins qui dorment
vu comment il m'a pris à partie
pratiquement mon chéri après toutes ces
émotions
je crois qu'il serait temps de regagner
notre cinquième à travers le papier au
gallon en ville des genêts machine
allez bon appétit mesdames merci et bon
dimanche vous tu m'aimes
si j'avais à choisir moi aussi
j'aimerais bien me promener dans les
bois au revoir c'est lucien et à bientôt
j'espère j'irai vous applaudir à de
séjour aux chapelles prévenu obtiendra
des taxes on est vite et plus tôt le
matin
[Applaudissements]
bod we signalé comme la boisson a encore
laissé sa voiture tant en font autant
vous l'avez déjà vu danser vous
mademoiselle huguette au oui mais sur la
scène au milieu des autres on ne la
reconnais guerre pourquoi et dans ce ca
t'intéresse aubin comme ça pour revenir
à josiane c'est fou ce qu'elle va être
contente de te revoir mon petit lucien
vous voyez au oui tiens tiens pas plus
tard que tout est là elle me disait tu
sais pas ce qu'elle m'a dit comme ça
mais si elle me dit comme ça y'a
longtemps à prendre l'avenue lucien oui
al mayakhi textuelle et forcément parce
que je viens d toi ça date pas d'hier
non mais quand je pense que quand on t'a
connu tu portais encore des culottes
courtes alors vraiment josiane vous
parlez de moi pas tout
lucien part si lucien par là même que
sans vouloir te vexer
on en avait par dessus la tête des bus
caston elle voulait même de tricoter un
pull une ambiance assez gentil et sait
comment sont les jeunes filles arrivent
sentimentale
bah oui mais je parle c'est elle qui
descend bon ça va lui donner un coup de
se retourner brusquement en face
d'autres fins comme ça ça sert
sm je me suis lavé les cheveux ce matin
on finissait pas de sécher alors au
moins c'est tout ce que tu dis à lucien
elle est bouleversée elle veut pas le
montrer
bon anniversaire josiane merci lucien ça
fait plaisir te voir alors ont déjà
demandé jeunes pas moi qui ai peur
d'être en retard faut mettre le couvert
si c'est pas trop demander donner un
coup de main à sa mère oh là là quelle
histoire pour trois assiettes et du
courrier pour moi et dimanche c'est vrai
c'est dimanche j'avais complètement
oublié au la glycine
vous avez vu la glycine qu'est ce
qu'elle à la glycine elle aussi bien
qu'à la maison
elle est d'un mot et elle sent bon et
ben jules qu'est ce que tu attends
prenez où seul le moussaoui monsieur
vraiment on peut compter sur leur âge et
cours
roy bennett est enfin installé à mon
ministère je reviens tout de suite
il a fini de rêvasser dis moi oui toi
petit malheureux aux luttes t'occuper de
ton fiancé mon fiancé à lucien wagon
qu'est ce que tu as tu dors plus malades
dont lucy hale est pas mon fiancé way
non mais avant je crois pour qu'il ne
soit quand je reviendrai dans 5 minutes
sinon je vais mettre à couvert mais je
vais t'aider ah non non non la suisse
tiendra bon ça va pas trop mal joué
témoin la très bonne mine tabac
forcément à la cambrousse là le grand
théâtre où là bas ah bah j'avais pas le
temps c'est que j'en ai mis un coup à la
mécanique matin je peux y aller tu sais
je te démonter un moteur pièce par pièce
un risque en le remontant one 2 il
dimanche
qu'est ce que tu faisais au y avait le
stade le foot ailier droit j'étais tu
aimes le foot doit choisir
abbas et parce que tu connais pas les
règles du jeu
y'a dimanche c'est si tu veux je t'amène
à la rencontre france belgique après tu
pourras plus manqué un match
merci je t'assure moi le foot je trouve
ça stupide stupide le foot
ah oui l'année des coups de pied dans un
ballon en enfin josiane dessous du sport
des goûts et des couleurs sais pas
pourquoi je suis là de parler de foot
qu'est-ce que tu es devenu toit pendant
tout ce temps ben tu vois le bureau est
toujours content pas content tu vois tu
tu t'entends bien avec des collègues
pensent que jean après moi teisseire
bonjour bonsoir sont toujours là à me
regarder par en dessous
ah tiens là dit ça va pas être finie
quand elles verront que je me suis lavé
les cheveux
josiane l'a vraiment pensé à moi
quelques fois oui bien sûr parce que moi
moi j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi
harry ah oui j'avais ta photo dans mon
portefeuille là je la regardais souvent
ça que je porte la france à l'image
comme tout je t'avais dit à déchirer
josiane si on se mariait tous les deux
je vais avoir une bonne situation
tu pourrais arrêter de travailler
quoique au début évidemment ça aiderait
petit à petit on se meuble vrai il y
aura peut-être moyen d'avoir une voiture
d'occasion qui dimanche mais on partir
en balade on qu'on pourrait le m'acheter
une tente et puis on était aux frais du
camping un fils ça veut dire on irait
danser et puis on n'aura pas besoin de
se presser pour avoir de la famille
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
c'est rien c'est vraiment dit qu'il
finisse de déjeuner alors qu'est ce que
tu en penses
de quoi au oui et bien sinon le sien
c'est non non bon ben ça tu sais je
t'aime bien mais ça non non non inutile
de te fatiguer pas la peine de me
répéter je vois les choses l'amour ça se
commande pas ouais j'ai emprunté par un
centre bien faire je t'aime beaucoup tu
sais bah oui même beaucoup mais peu ça
suffit pas merci pour ta franchise
josiane tu t'en vas tu pues très fin tu
m'excuseras prêté serment comme tu
voudras d'ailleurs j'ai un rendez vous
tout de suite après déjeuner je
comprends bonne chance
adieu aujourd'hui merci pour le pull
quelle bulle
adieu
[Applaudissements]
et oui les lucien il est parti pertusa
partie parce que je sais moi n'est pas
parti parti il va revenir pour aller
déjeuner ah non non il m'a changé de
l'excuser on peut être toi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé encore un ace qui s'est
encore passé france ont pris la tête
alors ma petite fille ne prendra ses
grands airs avec moi comme simple parce
que j'ai de la patience ne faudrait tout
de même pas que la série ce qui se passe
je ne croise il est lucien sur sa moto
il m'a bousculé sortirait pas reconnu si
tu veux des explications demandées à ta
fille je sous leur coordination
elle leur a manqué comme les autres ont
un coût social il serait temps qu'ils
mettent un peu d'eau dans son vin
insolente traite ont perdu gros au lapin
l'embellie tu veux d'abord tout ça c'est
de ta faute si tu n'avais pas tellement
gâtée pourrie elle ne répondrait pas sur
ce ton revenu n'est pas trop tard pour
la montée bah quoi il n'était pas gentil
ce garçon si tu mets ton cherchera des
conneries je ne cherche plus mais si on
vient me demander de l'épouser et bien
leur allure plutôt nos il est parti
chercher là bas
non maman j'ai refusé c'est fini je ne
serai jamais grand mais dit josiane
j'espère que ton rapport à le regretter
mais en ce qui me concerne je pouvais
pas souhaité mieux pour toi que lucien
lucien pouvait pas faire mon bonheur
mais qu'est ce que tu as ans et d'amal
et cela par les mamans quoi je veux pas
être la femme les mécaniciens veut pas
d'une petite fille ma dalton les enfants
la cuisine la télévision mais dimanche
je n'ai rien à se dire
toute la ville est en face de l'autre
jamais rien à se dire qu'est ce qu'il
raconte
on dirait ton parc lucien pas de
conversation pas il est arrivé un quart
d'heure avant toi puis je te jure qu'il
en a raconté des choses bien sûr c'est
grâce à lui fait pas d'embarras mais
pour ce qui sera le leur sa petite femme
et puis d'être un bon père de famille
alors là je suis tranquille quoi bon
discuter vous pouvez pas comprendre
mais mademoiselle a des idées de
grandeur mais qu'est ce que tu es après
tout une fille de concierge ni plus ni
moi parce que c'est un joli d'avoir de
l'ambition qui de rêver qu'on va
rencontrer le prince charmant comme ça
dans le métro helm et on te prend quatre
fois par jour mais ça fait un bon bout
de temps que tu a coiffé sainte
catherine
mais moi aussi j'étais comme toi et puis
tu vois j'ai épousé ton père
seuls les hommes c'est ni beaux ni très
fin seulement ils ont besoin des femmes
comme les femmes au besoin d'eux et
c'est c'est tout simple évidemment c'est
pas du cinéma
alors crois moi c'est en trouve à un
métier qui veux t'épouser d'un prend le
pas ce que celui de tu attends il existe
au paon assis il existe j'ai rencontré
qu'est ce que tu dis je suis fiancé
c'est tout non mais tu te manque de nous
là c'est extraordinaire fillon aussi au
pas enfin bravo a battu fait confiance à
quai par endroits la hauteur as tu sais
nous récompenser tout le mal que je
donnais pour toi mais si vous me l'aviez
laissé le temps c'est la première chose
que je voudrais a annoncé tout à l'heure
en descendant est qu après cette
naissance hier soir peut-être mais quand
maman tu me fais les salles parce que je
ne m'arrive pas qu'on fait le ciel parce
que je me marie
pourquoi tu ne devrais peut-être envoyé
à faire part comme un non pas tant mieux
c'est très content pour toi mais depuis
quand tu ne connais ce jeune homme parce
que je suppose qu'il s'agit d'un beau
jeune homme un mois alors ça comme
dissimulée nous avons le même âge
enfin presque il a deux ans de moins que
moi pourquoi j'aurais préféré le
contraire et où vous êtes vous
rencontrés à l'opéra comique en faisant
la queue
ilham la grande musique comme moi c'est
fou ce que nous nous sommes découverts
comme point commun puisqu'il fait dans
la vie de garçon une licence de droit
c'est un intellectuel un fils de famille
oui oui de très bonne famille parce que
c'est très joli étudiants mais faut
manger nous nous débrouillerons obtient
et tu connais tes futurs beaux parents
n'ont d'ailleurs il habite papa quand
même de bien sûr la déclaration se
présentera voilà oui tu as honte et
comment peut-il dire une chose pareille
si massive et si ta mère et moi on le
sent bien la crise sert sinon pourquoi
tous ces mystères se mord épouse un
monsieur
alors tu as honte de tes paroles qui
sont conscients oui c'est humain contre
est plutôt votre réaction avant qui
m'inquiète
tout comme si tu savais pas que tu nous
mène par le bout du nez voudrait
tellement qui vous plaisent est ce qu'il
t'a plu il nous plaira ben c'est pas sûr
ils pourraient vous surprendre à
première vue
l'or n'est pas plus difficile que toi de
moi et fils il est beau grand race et un
sourire d'une blancheur éclatante font
toujours très soignée je n'ai jamais vu
deux fois la même cravate à la cravate y
touche chic de leur panel l'an passé
parce que plus important quand même
marrant mais il est raffiné sensible
intelligent il a toutes les qualités il
hébrard blanc avait justement il est
prêt il est très bon à ses bras le type
espagnol
non non non non pas exactement
il est vraiment très bon
donc ça là
il est difficile de faire plus brap sa
barbe et ses cheveux sont noirs quoi oui
et ça pour aussi
sa peau ah oui ça pousse qu'est-ce que
ça de sucre ordinaire
il a la peau noire
je ne pouvais plus j'étais trop
malheureux j'aurais donné des bijoux
vous voulez savoir pourquoi je vais vous
le dire quand je suis arrivé le match
américaines étaient couchés tout nu au
milieu du salon d'une grosse lampe
ils attendent américaine en danger une
boîte de sardines en vivant du cheval en
parfaitement
on va tout de même pas par ce sont des
gens civilisés qui j'aurais donné mes
bijoux comme ces gens n'avaient rien dit
du tout vu qu'ils n'ont pas compris je
vous en supplie monsieur coffe dites moi
qu'est ce que je trouve n'importe quoi
mais aux français
ça me fera du bien foutez-moi le camp ya
pas de répéter deux fois le show non
mais c'est pas un ego à ce moment-là pas
passer l'année où ses pensées nous
arrive oui la méfiance et de la plus
pure ans africaine jamais eu l'intention
de location est due aux mesures sans
emphase soutient qu'une chose jamais
rien fait alors la jamais contente
jamais je te tuerais plutôt les forages
même gêné ont vécu toute sa vie dans
l'honneur et dans la dignité et presque
nécessaire que ses locataires pour que
notre fille unique épouse un [ __ ]
ok le monde je m'attendais à tout ça
leurs cris et leurs proches ne serviront
à rien
quoi vous fassiez ma décision est
inébranlable j'épouserai sans fin
comment dudit enfin mon bill et sauf à
ses centrales mobiles à savater bien
dans le quartier central problème
je me fiche des préjugés sans fard vaut
mieux tous les garçons j'ai rencontré
seulement sa peau n'a pas la même
couleur que la mienne c'est tout mais
regarde tes amis est-ce qu'elles
épousent des lettres pour moi sofa est
un homme pareil aux autres mais devant
la loi que tu fais respecter papa tous
les hommes sont égaux mais sont
peut-être tous égaux mais sont pas tous
de la même couleur
on remarque que je ne veux pas mal mais
enfin s'il pour dieu il la peine de
faire des hommes blancs qui des hommes
noirs c'est que tu dois les bornes n'y a
pas de plan j'apporte mois quand les
hommes apparurent sur la terre il
s'entendait tous seulement à ceux qui
vivaient dans les pays chauds
la nature à donner une bo pigmentées et
les cheveux crépus pour les protéger du
soleil
tiens-toi par exemple l'année dernière
aux sables-d'olonne
quand tu t'exposes est trop longtemps
c'est avec sa part été long capot a
changé de couleur
ben elle est devenue rouge c'est pas
pour ça que c'est devenu un bon mix
crimes au nom alors là j'ai pas le coeur
à plaisanter ça dure
enfin écoute josiane possède tout ce que
tu représentes pour nous tu es toute
notre vie alors tu me dis qu'amoureuse
garçon bon qu'il est beau fils et grands
qui les distinguaient vient de sa
personne je te comprends enfin je te
comprends je cherche à comprendre où le
mot petit josiane je t'en supplie même
si tu crois que c'est ça le bonheur
il faut renoncer à ce bonheur là m'enfin
que tu le veuilles ou non tu est
différente de lui mais ton père a raison
car rappelle toi la nièce du facteur ça
vient d'épouser un belge avec une si
belle voiture
elle était partie toute la rieuse et ben
n'a pas tardé à revenir alors tu te
rends compte si ça colle pas avec un
belge qu'est ce que ça sera avec allen
eh bien
reda la liste ya tout à l'heure qu'il a
retenu deux ans par l éducation de
france de formation française nous
parlons la même langue
j'ai donné ma parole à blanc prendra
qu'est-ce que tu t'imagines papa je vais
renoncer à l'homme de ma vie pour te
faire plaisir j'ai pas demandé à limay
mois bois personne n'empêchera jamais de
l'aimer alors va-t-on annonce maintenant
tout de suite très bien
josiane réfléchi une dernière fois si tu
passes le seuil de cette porte ne la
franchira jamais ça tu n'es plus rien
pour nous l'ancien évadé cela est une
malade du milieu d'une détraqué m'ont
fait chaud mais il est prêt mais the
navy vous n'êtes pas je m'interdis toute
fois qu'il avait préparé une si jolie
tard façon l'univers bourgeois
et
en gros j'ai pu te tutoie le voilà qui
revient monothéisme quel état le
dentiste et qu'elle dentiste il ya bien
un artiste dans cette maison oui merci
merci et un dimanche
écoutez madame c koi choisi bonjour pour
avoir une rage de dents pour la seconde
fois je vous le mahb le dentiste quel
état est un écriteau sur la porte qui
crève les yeux dr lahlou premier étage a
concédé la flèche qui savait pas dire
mais tu es mal pour cette maison j'ai
pas vu ça arrive mais bon alors c'est
pas chez le dentiste qui peut aller chez
le marchand deviner à quoi m serge vous
plaît
la concierge à quoi il sert à quoi le
faire à vous dire que vous essuyer les
pieds espèce de malpoli
tu fais j'ouvre la porte de la cour
pourquoi encore la chatte et voudrait en
venir
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez gagner pour vous 3 72 11 9%
est permis 70e 1 10-1 puis 10 à 17 14
ans ayant composé de julien fabre
elle est vraie
qui fait quoi
la polonaise d'ouvrir toutes grandes sa
radio eh ben tu vois jules tout à
l'heure quand elle va descendre saboteur
dur je lui ferai aucune observation
pourquoi t'es malade
non mais j'ai pas le coeur à me disputer
la chaleur on sera tous morts
la chaleur
je voudrais bien enfin peu de fraîcheur
qui tu es bon dans votre leurs autres
adam dunn n'ont jamais fait on nous
annonce un été torride
les trottoirs sont brûlants métal ont
enfoncé dans la sphère des envies oui
j'ai été chercher mon bâton à la sortie
de la samaritaine débuts sur chemin du
retour nous sommes arrêtés vont prendre
l'apéritif devant être en tort au 4ième
d'amber at on est d'accord
j'ai décidé comme si je pouvais lui
résister je prendrai le noir avec une
petite tache blanche sur le nez il
al'air futé comme vous avez raison de
vous décider
madame l'oiseau avait déjà un oeil de
sort pas mal d'années et est encore
parce que j'ai hâte de la voir mon petit
chat comme ça quand je ne serai pas là
ma germaine se sentira moins présente
allez viens on attend on va tout de
suite essayé de les trouver m
qu'est ce que tu penses de clovis
s'amusant clovis pour un chat bah non
c'est pas possible c'est tellement bon
grand-père
j'ai mal à vraiment 17 lui malgré la
chaleur oubliez pas de fermer la fenêtre
dans votre chambre on entend tout dans
la cour mais voilà tous quand j'ai les
petits 10 h à17 sultane elle nous en
aura fait voir
oui c'est bien comme ça on va pouvoir
partir se reposer pendant huit jours la
campagne partie 1
on va pas passer tout l'été ici noms qui
me tiens tu demanderas madame lefebvre
des arbres pour qu'elle me les noirs
auxquels les laisse mourir de soif
comme l'année dernière rien à faire je
garde tales of à bord you tell tale of
thé plantes passat intenta tu as
toujours des bonnes raisons d'y croire
si tu veux droit norbert mais la vérité
c'est toi non plus tu n'as pas beaucoup
envie de quitter paris six mois
vous êtes là pourquoi aujourd'hui je te
déshabille plus me parler d'elle seins
je te connais y pense on tente - jamais
mais plus rien pour moi et didier dur
moi mourir une fille qui nous a quittés
comme ça un bon jour pour un [ __ ] qui a
pas donné de ses nouvelles depuis des
semaines
il est peut-être gentil ce [ __ ] je veux
pas le savoir mais c'est avis aux mêmes
études en live un mot plus jouer au
bistrot là au moins il y aura personne
pour me parler d'elle
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que ça vous
pouvez le dire quand je pense qu'il va
quand même falloir énoncer ce soir comme
tous les soirs vous croyez que vous
aurez du monde
nous ferons le maximum comme d'habitude
mais quel public
ces hommes en bras de chemise je ne dis
pas ça pour vous messieurs peuvent quand
on est chez soi c'est différent les gens
ne savent plus de l'ird ans a écouté
tout à l'heure j'étais celle du plancher
est bien celui que va bousculer pour
être servis avant moi oh c'est pas
toujours dit vous savez être une femme
seule dans la vie la vie qui n'est pas
toujours gai 20h toujours pas de
nouvelles de lousiane
vous me demandez ça tous les jours
madame lefebvre josiane est en vacances
elle a mieux à faire qu'à écrire fera
plus de longues vacances cette année
elle est très bien même si chef c'est
drôle
qu'est ce que ce qui est drôle madame le
faire et ma fille soit bien vu de ses
chefs non non non je pensais simplement
une chose que marc dugain aa et qu'est
ce que la vie de cidre au musée le
guette et bien qu'il a semblé il ya
quelques jours
reconnaître l'ancien à la terrasse d'un
café du pont saint michel josiane votre
fille allumage hozjan
mais c'était sûrement miner puisqu'il
est absente de paris et d'ailleurs ce ne
pouvait être josiane tard il paraît que
la jeune fille en question était attablé
avec l ai dit
squillaci comique mon avis le faire on
fait que ma fille est peut être aperçue
en compagnie d'un jeune homme de couleur
mais josiane comme il faut parce que
d'après vous une jeune fille comme il
faut ne pas fréquenter un jeune homme de
couleur non mariés pour quelque chose à
dire au fait qu'un jeune soit de couleur
en a fallu pour ses palaces
bon alors nous sommes bien d'accord les
noirs sont des gens comme les autres au
dessus n'empêche qu'ils ont une odeur
space talent qu'elle en donne pas mais
je ne sais pas personnellement j'en ai
jamais senti c'est connu
j'ignore elle et puis quand ça les prend
ils violent les femmes
remarquez on ne parlera vouloir sont des
enfants
vous en avez connu au spectacle il ya
trois figurants au noir gars tous les
soirs je leur dit bonsoir a gentiment
télémesure ce qui prouve bien que je
n'ai aucun préjugé
alors parce que vous leur dites
pansements vous pensez que c'est
suffisant pour pouvoir les juger et je
ne juge pas parce qu'un pas que je dise
qu'on peut prendre tout simplement je
répète ce qu'on dit et ben faut pas se
fier à ce qu'on dit même la faire parce
que le pq de 20 ans dans toute l'île
saint louis
on répète bien que feu monsieur lefebvre
on n'a jamais vécu dans votre
imagination
pourtant les mauve et blanc eelv aura
lieu un acte de mariage préparer mon
dîner mais bon ce jeune homme
comment se fait-il qu'à ma fille et moi
même nous rencontrions jamais habitants
pour ainsi dire au porte à porte
faut croire que nous n'avons pas les
mêmes heures de travail j'espère que
dorénavant en lisant aux pitchouns
[Applaudissements]
alors lucien a savamment la [ __ ] con
t'as pas vu ça va très content ouais ça
va ça va comme ça m'a pas que voulez
vous pour servir nous on t'aime bien mon
petit lucien de 7,6 avait fait de nous
la lui madame boeuf alors qu'est ce qui
t'amène ben ben voilà monsieur bof j'ai
un taxi dans la porte
ah parce que tu te balades en taxi doit
maintenant c'est à dire que quelqu'un
dans le taxi
mais quelqu'un vous devinez paquin
quelqu'un qui voudrait bien vous voir
tiens ce gâchis bouge pas cette personne
qui est dans le taxi c'est le désire
tellement nous voir pourquoi n'est pas
venu tout seul là pas besoin de toi pour
faire les présentations se connaît il
faut croire qu'elle faisait pas mais tu
n'as pas en reste il a discuté pendant
10 heures avec ta vie piétons sur le
trottoir j10 alors que l'envoyé donc non
elle m'a téléphoné je suis allé la voir
mais pas rancunier c'est pas parce qu'il
m'a refusé qu'on est plus copains alors
qu'est ce qu'elle voulait avoir de vos
nouvelles
elle se faisait du souci alors j'ai
pensé que le meilleur moyen de la
rassurer basse était encore de vous
l'amenez j'ai bien fait et a parlé de sa
vie à jouer pas posé de question j'ai
respecté son silence
son papa bonjour
puis embrassent mandat fille josiane
d'embrasser ton père c'est une fée c'est
peut-être là c'est vraiment pas la peine
bah écoute à quoi tu t'attendais tu tu
penses que tu sais en colère mais
j'espérais qu'il allait me pardonne
non il t'a déjà pardonné depuis n'ont
pas tu perds ma peur non je crois que
c'est l'heure de dîner alors je vais
vous laisser en famille
j'allais dire que tu ne puisses entendre
le sien restait lucien devant presque
m'offre n'osera contrôle à disputer bon
alors c'est une visite de courtoisie où
je compte revenir ici définitivement
ça dépend de toi papa mais ta chambre tu
attends ma petite fille j ai même
profité pour l'absence pour la vt rideau
commerci ils ont pas trop répressive
quand les choses s'arrangent très bien
entre vous
comment il semble que moi aussi j'ai
droit à quelques explications parce que
l'on parvient c'est vraiment trop facile
et ne la brusque pas elle peut pas
toujours raconté comme ça de but en
plein josi a déjà fait le premier pas
c'est l'essentiel
allez faites pas plus méchant que vous
l'êtes monsieur veut enfin benoît sans
nouvelles pourquoi pas deux ans ses
parents comptent bien peu pour toi ma
fille ou son désert tient à l'hôtel où
j'habite
parce que tu lis à l'appel mais pourquoi
tu dis ça peut rapporter avec madame
taxi parce que je savais moi comment
vous allez moi se voir à quoi tu es
majeure non tu paies ta chambre là haut
alors qu'est ce que j'ai à voir là
dedans tu veux revenir tu reviens moi tu
es libre d'ailleurs tout ce qu'on me
demande mon avis dans cette maison
mes bagages sont tout près et décalé les
chercher robert gillet rapallo ça
m'ennuie lucien que tu t'appuies encore
cette corvée ben comme ça la situation
sera réglée c'était gentil quand même
oui à l'oreille ça il est gentil mais
parce que j'en connais à sa place il ya
une petite note à payer tu as beaucoup
en ce moment donc bien 400 le buzz
commence à comprendre on te demande va
comprendre vu notamment de payer
tout serait papa soit 38 moore mais que
tu as fait pas partie de ma fille a tout
de suite en battant brest où le service
est compris après y'a pas grand chose
pour aller dîner la pauvre petite
heureusement il reste de la blanquette
big air me dit je vais te la faire
réchauffer tu aimes toujours la
blanquette de veau est ce que tu voudras
on en mange
j'ai pas très fin
on va écouter ainsi et toi restons comme
invisibles ils n'ont pas d'euros dit
choses sur moi les gens de la maison
c'était en interne de vacances des
vacances
selon le saunier de départ du temps
poser c'est un mal en tout cas madame le
fait on perd l'uhabia river son clou et
pas plus tard que tout à l'heure
bon josiane mettons les choses au point
une fois pour toutes
enfin que jamais y revenir
nous a fait beaucoup de peine j'espère
que tu de rencontres tu débuté aussi oui
peut-être
voilà tout accable pas un fat et des
revenus bon bah alors parlons plus
passant l'épongé plus
après tout il y en a d'autres que toi
qui ont fait la même bêtise à ton âge
une bêtise tu appelles l'homme de ma vie
une béquille à ben apparaît excuse moi
parce que je savais pas qu'il s'agissait
de l'homme de ta vie alors qu'est ce que
t'en as fait de l'homme de ta vie il a
été obligé de partir brusquement pour
l'afrique partie eh ben c'est le coup
classique ça voilà qu'est ce que tu as
in u mais depuis quand est-il parti
josiane 15 ou baby naturellement de [ __ ]
a pas de nouvelle annonce un c'est pas
voilà mais je m'en doutais envoyer de
l'argent comme ça il le rejoindra pas
parce que tu as l'intention d'aller le
rejoindre là-bas voilà pourquoi il t'a
pas emmener avec lui
pourquoi parce qu'il voulait d'abord
préparer ses parents préparaient ses
parents
ils ne savent pas ils ne savent pas quoi
que nous sommes mariés
marié pour de bon à la mairie du 5e
arrondissement marié a régulièrement tu
n'as pas fait ça tes parents tu n'as pas
fait ça à nous non plus on ne savait pas
mais je constate que je les legs ont agi
avec plus de ménagement
oh vous deviez bien vous en doutez banon
a non alors excuse nous mais non on
espérait au moins qu'un écran jusqu'à là
quand même
alors tu vois là marie mai puis plaqué
un mois à toi la plaque et ce au
contraire sauf ardente est très inquiet
mais sa chanson nouvelles sensations oui
parce qu'il ignore sans doute que toi
aussi tu as des parents ce monsieur
non ils vous savez opposé à notre
mariage enfin récapitulons qu'est ce
qu'il a dit exactement avant de partir
que nous serions bientôt réunis bientôt
bientôt mais ça peut être au paradis
mais qu'est ce qu'il est il n'a pas fixé
de date précise il pouvait pas savoir
avance je sais pas moi
il sera arrivé quelque chose salette ce
sera perdu à vous fatiguer qu'est ce que
c'est son pays faisant bout jamais
entendu parler de ce pays dame il est
vrai que c'est pas une référence
je vous sais ce trouble dans le sud de
l'afrique
c'est un état libre oui capitale quand
ça quand tu as well
oui je veux bien mort
et alors qu'est ce qu'il fait on pas ton
mari la bat puisque marie envie les eaux
fort et de bonne famille je dirais même
de très bonne famille oui oui oui
les six modèles ce qui m'avait caché
jusqu'à notre union son nom qui est un
personnage extrêmement important ce qui
fait souvent ils rêvent
il règne sur quoi sur le pays
c'est normand au bon alors là
je ne jouerai pas faire d'appel mais en
afrique tout le monde est roi non mais
j'en ai vu un et où sera à l'elysée un
jour j'ai peut-être service vient mon
oncle à moi il a 25 me dettes accord 300
femmes le droit de battre monnaie
celui de vie et de mort sur ce sujet et
une énorme bosse bon alors que tu vas me
faire le plaisir de nous souffler mot à
personne de cette histoire est de
retrouver ta petite vie bien tranquille
comme si tu rentre de vacances 1 nous on
sait je t'assure que ça suffit la balle
à dieu merci dieu merci le divorce est
pas fait pour les chiens
bon il n'est pas question de divorce je
viens de me marier oui bah tu changeras
d'avis dans quelques mois pour avoir
jamais c'est pas le jour à d'aménager un
piano à queue mais voilà voilà ta valise
josiane merci je penserai c'est faux ce
que tu as été vite on penserait prendre
de tes nouvelles demain enfin sachez
seulement que tout ce que peuvent dire
les mauvaises langues moi ça m'est égal
et à moi dont je voulais te dire
simplement et devant tes parents que mes
sentiments n'ont pas changé at on des
gars écoute lucien belle laisse le finir
quand même si tu veux quand tu veux je
t'épouse encore mais plus on ne dit rien
[Musique]
mais je ne suis pas libre lucien ils
l'aiment
moi je savais qu'une répondre sms
qu'elle te dit pas assez que le monsieur
il a filé sans laisser d'adressé et qui
a de grandes chances pour qu'ils ne
reviennent jamais certes je suis pas
pressé je t'attendrai josiane et battant
t'attends tu veux que je te dise attend
ça chante moi de mon côté je l'attendrai
mon bébé tombé attend un bébé
oui la haye me fiche la paix tous les
trois ans ça fait rien je prends le bébé
aussi
on dira on dira simplement que je suis
le père
ça me paraît plus difficile alors mais
pousse partout noir gilles
recette qui a fait rouler
concierge sauvage
mais comment ça casse chevrolet
ah ouais je comprends rien là
évidemment ça complique un peu les
choses wouah qu'est ce que tu veux dire
bah rien
en fait on va aller donner ce télégramme
pour toi à l'hôtel maintenant je peux te
le donner je tenais grave
c'est pourquoi tu ne l'as pas donné tout
de suite je voulais d'abord de parler
pour que tu puisse choisir une dernière
fois à la nature et aimant je pouvais
pas me douter que l'entrée en
compétition avec un maigre ce [ __ ]
comme tu dis est mon mari
je n'ai jamais hésité une seconde entre
lui et toi adieu josiane et on est multi
attentats portent comme ça lucio asesino
reviendra pas
alors je m'amuse à me décider d'ouvrir
et
bah alors qu'est ce qui est des ébats
josiane papa de cause au cours des cds 7
couronnement prévu pour la nouvelle lune
c'est quand la nouvelle lune
là bas c'est quoi leur m
tu attends impatiemment matin le passé
attend impatiemment mais il parle pas
souvent de l'argent du voyage
j'ai pas terminée mandat suis pile
ajoute voilà ça c'est pour moi alors
vous êtes convaincu pas convaincu quand
je verrai le mandat égalera il viendra
plus vite que tu me pense et moi
j'allais retrouver au pharo mais je
pense l'oncle de sa femme n'avait pas
d'enfant ça a même failli lui coûter son
tronc je m'en souviens très bien
by ap hm d'orphelins c'est déjà moins
triste
sofa et les n'était zombies l'aimé il
indiqué avec un peu de chance ils
varient pedreno to kill valérie t il
fait du couronnement m et que je suis
bête si le roi sûr je suis la reine
mentionne la dernière de mes amis rue
des près d'accord ce montage josiane oui
madame alice et je suis rennes à vous
avez passé un concours de beauté à
aussonne et non à la valise ou sur elle
j'ai épousé un roi ont écumé fait pas
attention mais la vanille ça déraille tu
vas te faire
et avec une vertu mais de même malice et
québec l épaule pas fait dans tout le
quartier laura palmer jeu tout le monde
le sache est toujours concerné est
intentions de vote n'étaient pas madame
alice et en 3d photo benjamin l'humanité
passe mais je suis dit c'est gagné
qu'est-ce que tu es poussière n'a pas vu
l'enfant paraît quoi oublier que
j'épouse un monsieur ses projets à roi
qu'est ce que vous foutez moi quel droit
un droit parfaitement pourquoi je
confirme mal avec les gibbons pistons
parce que si je reste donc le plaisir de
faire un scandale qu'il était temps pour
faire
comme à nant et maromme quelle robe
maroc de partage celle que je portais au
mariage de la cousine maurice tu pourras
faire je les payais essayer tout de
suite oui combien pour les photographes
ok je sais maintenant discuter si tu
veux tu portes eu la forêt je plante pas
par terre l'un et remerciant le quartier
dessus là non pas celui là c'est mon
renard merci donc à tous avec moi le
payant mais ma parole
comprenez pour la reine cette manif pour
elana talibans
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui se
passe j'étais au lit avec monsieur
raymond dit j'ai vite jeté un peignoir
sur mes épaules j'étais déjà couché à
cette heure si l'on est passé du propre
unis nous étions allongés à main avant
le 10 mai nous reposer un peu rien de
grave
roberval havrais bondi j'ai épousé un
roi un roi noir mais submergé fait
entonner je vous embrasse bravo et merci
pour les flexions nouvelle mais pourquoi
dont le poids l'amour moi je prends à
tout ce qui est un peu sans voix la vie
vous prenez la peine d'être avec un roi
au noir pas vraiment
deux fois le lieu d'une eh ben c'est pas
tous à l'alimentation m permets moi dit
la reine garde la loge je vais chercher
mon relais
[Applaudissements]
mais oui mais oui je cian voilà elle ne
brille pas un peu sous les bras alors
non non ça ira il ya de quoi la
rallonger à on peut gagner le cm avec un
faux son relais de sortie manille et
dans ses pas assez pour une traîne tout
mon temps que je m'habitue à évoluer et
à porter la couronne
non la couronne envers octobre en
attendant exercez-vous donc avec un rond
de serviette sur la peur
chacun se pose elle y est j'ai une idée
mademoiselle but on a besoin de vous
bonsoir josiane c'est vrai ce que
raconte la malice que vous êtes devenu
ray excusez moi ça me prend une douche
froide vous ferez mademoiselle huguette
nous avons besoin de vous prêter nous
votre diadème le diadème que je porte
pour passer mékong ou non je ne prête
pas rien qu'un instant vous voir l'effet
sur le sien mais j'y tiens beaucoup au
plus d'ailleurs moment ne voudra pas la
mer le faire je m'en charge
attendez moi je reviens
[Applaudissements]
déculottée 7 raimondi remarquer que moi
j'ai rien demandé à eau
josiane vous êtes déjà en grande tenue
vous croyez que vous aurez souvent
l'occasion de vous habiller comme ça n'a
pas je croyais qu'on vivait quasiment
tout nu chez les [ __ ] en tant qu
parisienne j'ai une réputation
d'élégance à soutenir et vous ne
craignez pas d'être un peu dépaysé au
début où j'aurai tellement de choses à
faire
le dispensaire tous les matins oui oui
je tout un programme
une bibliothèque roulante des cours de
coupe pour jeunes filles
et puis alors l'information alors
qu'est-ce pour donner des concerts de
musique classique et deux ou trois fois
par mois
réception au palais quelle aventure et
vous n'avez pas me purple au père de
quoi à mon dieu non mais je ne fais pas
de ce pays
des moustiques des moeurs primitif est
une école enfantine de l'afrique mac et
huguette et vous verrez la boisson
nationale à face à la bière ben ali sont
civilisés on va vous voilà comblés
puisque vous avez trouvé le mari idéal
je vous ferai venir comme ça
qui sait peut-être y trouver vous l'âme
soeur merci josiane mais moi j'ai pas
besoin d'aller chercher si loin ma vie
j'ai moins ambitieux il en faut aussi
des copeaux intitulé well as diable r
oui j'ai plus de force
mais regardez mon éventail oui très
souvent en photo les rênes sa porte des
éventails mézidon is des plus hauts
c'est un cadeau de mariage note l'ademe
d'abord d' il manque quelques pierres
sous les projecteurs ça brille quand
même bon bon c'est juste pour essayer
là haut vous êtes fait pour porter la
couronne josiane et vous trouvez bon
alors les entailles maintenant a
évidemment sa complète
quelle allure quel port qu'elle a
rapporté drôlement chouette global
d'idron gamin depuis quand on me dit toi
tu bon là pardon majesté très sage il
veut quelque chose mais je venais
seulement vous admirer une reine j'en ai
jamais vu de près et bas profitent
vraiment vieux parce que je vais pas
rester longtemps dans cette loge mon
royaume eric la police d'anvers et les
cartes postales aussi c'est comme ça que
vous serez sur les timbres j'en veux
pour ma collection roddick josiane vous
penserez à donner une décoration nous
ratons mais oui madame raimondi la reine
va faire votre mari officier du grand
orgue de la noix de coco
qu'ils attrapent espèce d'idiot
attention en avant le talent génial il
va plus en reste et fichiers on attend
d'ici tous les trois au bas si on peut
plus rire à l'impérialisme et nerveux
venez mesdames je vous offre l'apéro en
face je propose pas la reine de nous
accompagner sur le zinc se serait
déplacé vous croyez que je peux y aller
dans cette tenue au pour une fois sa
passion
dr lahlou s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que
c'est nous acteurs là nous quel état je
m'attache à droite la minuterie d'abord
gauche en bas des escaliers
merci super l'âge je garde la loge avec
sa sur la tête tu portes bien képi
parlement dont mon uniforme à
j'ai eu des maux à l'alimentation
générale bien ce qu'on t'a fait un
moment que choisissait un camembert et
bien dit pas tout d'un coup d'un
marchand de mélange de derrière son
comptoir et alors la mer quand vous
aurez fini
la boutique s'est mise à rire en
regardant ses tenues tout rouge et je
suis parti en oubliant la monnaie et
puis jose 3 y retourner qu'est ce cas
c'est encore madame hobby les afars je
vous prie c'est ici oui mais quel étage
qu'est-ce que vous ne les voulez je
désire lui parler personnellement c'est
moi
madame barons du père et de la follette
chef du protocole enchanté je viens
solliciter de votre majesté d'honneur
d'une audience pour monsieur le ministre
des affaires étrangères qui désire lui
présenter ses hommages au nom du
gouvernement de la république
c'est très gentil et oui mais justement
le ministre se rendrait au bal à
l'elysée mais il a tenu sans plus
attendre à saluer votre majesté daignera
tel le recevoir
oh mais ne laissez pas dehors qui lance
voyons maman vite une chaise pour
monsieur le ministre votre majesté me
permettent elles de là les chercher
un mini dans la maison vide laissé par
la porte de guerre c'est le ministre des
affaires étrangères a tenté de déranger
rendu des jeux wii à la voiture est
garée là avec les motards a quand même
que j'en connais un seul poteau un peu
tous les deux patrons alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait arthur ans ton très con mais
tu puisses pas perdre ma cuisine
oh là là ces légendes entre-temps sur
les voilà madame
des déchets depuis l'avènement au drôle
de sa majesté l'oiseau fait j'ai tenu à
venir le présenter les félicitations du
gouvernement de la république
c'est très gentil à vous monsieur le
ministre et à la république
asseyez vous vous n'êtes pas si pressé
je suis sauvé madame d'être le premier à
m'incliner devant la jeune et charmante
souveraine qui règnera désormais sur le
zombie va dire que ça a été une surprise
ce sera aussi madame et compiègne
agréable pour le peuple favorisés qui
accueillera bientôt dont la guest votre
auguste personne procès dont monsieur le
ministre
ça va les changer une règle ans et alors
comme ça vous allez à lille
et oui madame c'est la dernière
réception officielle de la saison
mais ce qu'il explique à votre majesté
l'apic porte monsieur le ministre mais
mon uniforme un peu pompeux et solide en
passant le seul ministre je trouve que
deux présidents auraient pu me faire
signe à william attendra que ça à paris
puis c'était l'occasion ou jamais de
faire connaissance comment votre majesté
n'a pas reçu son invitation
je m'étonne vraiment sans aucun doute le
carton se seraient égarés mais oui sans
aucun doute
il y avait une lettre conjointe diane
j'avais remarqué
il faut absolument réparer cette erreur
regrettable
mon cher veuillez sa part loeb les
chances de faire immédiatement le
nécessaire mais certainement si votre
majesté mais autorise je vais téléphoner
un continent
je suis navré et madame franchement
navré de ce malentendu c'est pas pour
dire monsieur le ministre mais on est
vite informé aux affaires étrangères
votre majesté trop bonne tiens je vois
comment collègue de l'intérieur a déjà
pensé à assurer la sécurité de votre
majesté
ce gardien de la paix ça c'est papa
monsieur votre père vraiment permettez
moi de vous présenter
monsieur boeuf monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
l'album en ce charme ne pas pas qui
veille sur son illustre fille monsieur
le ministre que vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion souvent de rencontrer drm
comme moi c'est madame toutes n'ont pas
votre grâce votre naturel
en un sens on peut dire que moi aussi
j'ai l'habitude découlent
votre majesté ne renie pas ses origines
c'est le signe de la fin est noble est
ce celle du coeur et j'ose vous le
rappeler madame le coeur de l'arène du
son bo est aussi celui d'une française
mais je n'oublie pas celui de notre
majesté peu beaucoup pour la france pour
la france pour l'europe pour l'
équilibre mondial
je permets d'attirer votre attention
madame sur les ressources prodigieuse et
inexploité du sol et surtout du sous sol
sur lequel votre majesté est appelé à
régner ya de la boue sans doute aussi
bref c'est la monnaie courante si j'ose
dire
le gisement qu'importe de l'uranium
j'aurais préféré des diamants de votre
majesté se consolent l'uranium y
pourvoira j'en ai beaucoup de l'uranium
de quoi faire sauter le monde
ah ça c'est magnifique hélas pour le
moment ce métal rare et s'il n'existe
qu'à l'état de promesses
il faut poser des mines extrait veulent
traiter le minerai la france de grand
père offre ses ingénieurs ses capitaux
son matériel aux en bo7 nations amies à
laquelle maintenant madame
grâce à vous nous unissent des liens de
famille on n'entre pas coli voir madame
chauffage bon et ryan a signé un lièvre
et merci pour le pourquoi de cette
visite fait madame ses promesses et le
mans ouvrent dont josiane ajoutent à
leur maman y'a du que votre majesté ne
se gênent surtout pas pour moi je ne
résiste pas à masquer
c'est un centre caviar du cac vient pas
des noms mais s'ils quittent la vraie se
veut pas de toi moi je me demande qui
par exemple sans doute l'ambassade de
quelques puissances étrangères
un quelqu'un vient me coûte pas cher
vous voyez que nous sommes pas les seuls
à profiter bien informé madame je prends
pouvoir à lancy à votre majestic sans
grand risque de me tromper
l'arrivage prochain de quelques autres
colis oui une caisse twistick par
exemple parler mais non par d'autres à
ça votre majesté va être comblé à ma
petite reine vont prendre gesterra souci
ils ont si sûr de donner la préférence à
ce camp et non sincère et désintéressée
porte généreusement à protéger de son
beau j'irai pour le mieux de mon pays
monsieur le ministre
dorénavant vous savez deux pays madame à
non monsieur le ministre
non je suis comme un négatif de photos
vous me voyez blanche mais en réalité je
suis noir la paix du monde est entre vos
mains la responsabilité il dira que j'ai
même pas de quoi prendre vos billets
pour aller dans votre royaume
hop hop mais qu'à cela ne tienne le
gouvernement de la république française
serait très heureux de mettre un avion à
la disposition de votre majesté
monsieur le président de la république
me prit d'insister auprès de sa majesté
si cela est possible et si sa majesté
n'a pas d'autre engagement pour qu'elle
lui fasse le très grand honneur
d'assister aux balles qu'il donne ce
soir à l'elysée pourquoi pas du tout
prête
j'accepte à mais je vous préviens
monsieur le ministre si le président
veut d'en profiter pour essayer de me
faire signer un traité faisait venir
avec vous r2 pas y toucher il tombera
sur un fait le président la crise est
bien là mais le fait vous y allez pas
faites comme chez vous où rien n'est pas
que l'art est donne une audience au
ministre
votre majesté ne faut rater l'honneur de
partager ma voiture ne veut nous en
mettrons une dès demain à la disposition
de votre majesté mais c'est pas de refus
ça ira plus vite que le métro pour faire
mes courses
votre majesté étaient prêts à partir
nous attendons le bon vouloir de sa
majesté
allons messieurs à l'elysée
josy public et à fourrure
on a là là là pour but la teinturière
sera devant sa porte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car nous y
quelle heure est il qu'est ce qu'il ya
j'entends une voiture alors ils en
passent de voiture dans la rue madame
raymonde et
[Musique]
c'était seulement hubert sur son
triporteur
certes ça finira bien par être ou pas
j'ai fumé toute la quête cigarettes de
mon mari quand on a quand on est nerveux
et bien madame alice quand vous aurez
fini de molière la pyramide marc aussi
c'est nerveux
en général j'aime pas le sucre est tu
crois qu'ils ont pris la vie en ville
j'en sais pas plus de toit si on
téléphonait partout à orly et au bourget
tes collègues qui savent rien j'ai déjà
dit non on doit pourtant avoir prévu un
service d'ordre sais pas comment tu
t'arranges m'étais jamais au courant de
rien bon écoute écoute moi bien
grappiller le connaît la brette
reconnaît le chemin selon une reine ça a
des obligations
ils ont certainement organiser une
grande réception avec jarque de fleurs
la marseillaise tout le tremblement et
la petite se trouve coincé là bas et
bahia qu'à attendre la nave région
monsieur burns qu'elle va plus vers ces
chapitres viendra vous embrassiez ya
quatre ans
attendons à l'eau
c'est walbert de la dernière sacré coûte
100 par l' annonce voit bien qu'on n'a
pas caché le roi et la reine sur la
table comme elles l'ont fait je sais pas
monsieur boeuf moi c'est pour vous qui
m'inquiète mais n'y a vraiment aucune
raison de s'inquiéter
est-ce qu'on s'inquiète regarde ton est
calme
jon de livraison vip les rues sont
décorées ya le portrait de la reine
josiane dans chaque vitrine l'a vu la
charcuterie lattès montet toutain bout
d'un métier elle pâtissier dont il a dû
stone est un mal les initiales de la
reine josiane sont en sucre filé et la
couronne en nougatine
on ne mangera assaël et fêter notre
josiane vous connaissez beaucoup de fans
qu'ils soient nés dans les salles robin
vous savez moi je nique n'est plus tout
seul là où il a fallu que je descends de
nouvelles elle va vous êtes descendus
pour rien donné
on est une chaise madame préfère vous ne
tiendrez compagnie
qu'est ce que disait le télégramme
arriveront demain baiser arrive ou donc
son mari l'accompagnent combat il vivait
aussi il ya des chances
votre petit fils mme clinton dont le
prince six semaines et ne voudra pas
vraiment le baptême de l'air pas soutien
de nombreux trésors dont vous ignoriez
tout le royaume tout jusqu'à hier soir 0
voulait nous faire une surprise
ils y reviennent pour longtemps parce
qu'en principe il faut les rois et les
reines c'est comme les fonctionnaires
car ça n'a pas droit demont vacances oui
enfin ce sont eux qui décident quand
même y'a personne au dessus
c'est pas faux que ce round final ma
lessive c'est moi la dame américaine ne
va pas être contente un bain je vous
appellerai par la coume dame alice
hockey
mais bale n'est pas une cigarette pour
moi par hasard je suis vraiment dit non
merci provoque la tâche ou des divers
moi je m'étonne qu'on ne pas croiser
leur arrivée dans les journaux l'accueil
est ok ce que vous en faites madame
l'incognito ils vont habiter ici vous
voulez rien de me le faire
habitué au luxe et aux honneurs comme
elle l'est maintenant ma josiane elle se
sentirait trop à l'étroit ici ma bosse
en plus je n'oubliais c'est pas votre
avis mais là vraiment digne un madame
rien dit oh pardon vous dites mais vous
vous rappelez bien les êtres de josiane
que je vous ai lu à huy un véritable
conte de fées
sa chanson qui grossit strike rôle et ça
fait deux nuits hauteur de sa piscine
avec balais et peu de bengale
évidemment c'est merveilleux j'en
conviens mais personnellement je préfère
quand même qu'ils sont un peu moins
huppés et un peu plus à bois et bien
puisque choisie elle tarde à arriver je
vais aller enfiler une robe ça plus
convenable on n'agit pas un super héros
n'est donc avec moi pour reprendre
toutes les bouteilles vides
ma cuisine linge est en règle si la
patronne me demande monsieur parce que
je lui dirai qui tu es monté en service
chez l'homme a vraiment des gens mais
pour cinq minutes
ça va être vite fait
[Musique]
comment ça va disperser les curieux
ballet rosas abrite en outre les
parapluies de vous a su que plus on peut
partir sans avoir vu l'un vrais amis
sont gentils tous ces gens là regardez
les c'est la gloire
bonjour y avait tellement de monde
devant la porte du passé par derrière
personne n'a vu leur garde alors avec
mon voyage allait bien mais où est le
roi des phares et ben oui oui ton mari
elle est restée à orly pour s'occuper
des bagages du vainqueur 1 0 mais une
valise s'étaient égarés il y avait
beaucoup de monde pour vous recevoir
ah non personne c'est vraiment ce qu'on
peut appeler le plus strict a connu les
quoi croyez-vous qu'elle est restée
simple mail rennes ça peut tous permet
de voir ce que je le pose du bal obtus à
l'opti ces sales petits ils font
comme sa prime ous ne réveillez pas
surtout il a brillé pendant tout le
voyage parce qu'il a dû faire ses taux
alors par semaine et ce après classement
mais le la sur le lien en appréhendant
souhaité faire un petit peu parce qu'il
fut manchots et oui voilà mon bonheur
bisous
puis en temps gilles un vrai besoin
mais il ne peut pas être noir
complètement s'attend pas non plus à ce
qu'il soit complètement blanc n'est pas
noir noir je sais pas moi vas-y voir un
autre m'a d'abord j'ai comme une
angoisse au creux de l'estomac alors
tous les deux ensemble
allez courage
tosi
bush la place au pp et elle a même eu
droit aux
son papa pourra par le ramier j'aurais
du mal à me a river que c'est la chair
de ma chair
ah ça il est marrant
comment s'appelle ce jésus defarges il
faut faire comme son père et j'ai eu
comme son compère et il est costaud pour
son âge
je pense bien il pèse 9 livres tout d'un
coup comme ça de trois quarts c'est
frappant mais oui madame lefebvre ce qui
peut vous ressemblez monsieur pas
attendu alors dans l'expression de sa
royale de mines allez laissez le
tranquille ces petits vous allez
l'étouffer l'info tirer spirale épouse
trois juges va faire bouillir le lait
je vis de décembre eh bien je crois que
je vais vous laisser pas ce que vous
avez certainement beaucoup de choses à
vous dire
nous veillerons josiane rester ici
quelques temps howie quelques temps je
crois c'est déjà mieux
au final qu'est ce qui se passe se
trouve bizarre il se passe ça parce que
je suis bien contente des prix
quand on a la paix perdu l'habitude de
porter des souliers quel supplice
bah quoi n'aurait pas des yeux comme des
soucoupes supporter mon costume national
simplement c'est un roc de tous les
jours t'as pas peur d'attraper froid toi
là dedans j'ai rien d'autres admettent
mois alors maman quoi de neuf dans
l'immeuble 29 donc pas grand chose bon
là vous dire ça fait du bien de se
retrouver chez soi alors qu'il aime
toujours tes vieilli l'âge ça va quand
même pu faire avant le changement va
quitter son palais ah ben oui c'est vrai
topal et wifi libre il est grand il
raconte nous allez mon palais mon palais
où on peut parler ça exactement un
salaire à huy [ __ ] sato quoique non
non ça ça n'a rien à château non plus
mais c'est comme une grande villa au
bord de la mer puis écoutez c'est déjà
ça voyez le cabanon de tonton et tantine
argenteuil
là ce sera assez dans le même genre mais
en plus grand
ça rien ne sert à rien à palais alors là
vraiment ni d un chaton ont ni même
d'une grande villa au bord de la mer pas
à côté du reste là bas on pouvait dire
quand même que c'était un palais
pourquoi commencer le reste des huttes
en boue séchées des des baraquements et
puis puis des bidons des panneaux du
bidon et vieux bidons c'est pas du tout
ce que tu nous raconter d'antenne est
enfin je rêve je faisais des projets
l'interprétait les choses alors c'est
moche
dans un sens oui plutôt
à ce point là encore sa vie à dieu quand
même temps son coin déjà un bon ménage
ah non non non non non non loin d'oran
dauphin m'aider à tout supporter alors
dû me moque tout va bien dans ton ménage
avec ton arrivée les sens
ben oui pis pour le reste est pas avec
le temps tu finira bien par t'habituer y
en a beaucoup qui voudraient bien d'être
à temps plein parce que justement elle
est libre tu es plus rêve comment ça tu
n'es plus rennes gprs que j'ai perdu mon
trop a longtemps ils en auront vu thema
leurs parents
tu peux la première à qui ça arrive non
mais comment ça tu as perdu ton trône
j'ai perdu entre autres parce que le roi
mon mari a été renversé loc
bon alors là c'est le bouquet mais aussi
mon ne se met pas en droit quand on
n'est pas capable
safar était un monarque admirable mais
qu'est ce qui s'est encore pas ce qu'est
ce que tu as encore fait un
qu'est ce que tu vas encore faire pour
que ton mari père de son trop espèces de
grenouilles parce qu'enfin tout de même
un trône ça se perd pas comme ça mais on
ne voulait pas d'une reine blanche c'est
tout
les l'aigre il te reprocher d'être
lensois oui franchement bon sang
qu'est-ce qu'ils auraient donc voulu que
je sois noir imagine toi
par exemple moi je veux progresser leur
faire beaucoup d'honneur que de leur
donner une reine blanche
enfin ils sont pas trouvé pourquoi au
nom mais il ya une raison politique le
souverain va ya quelques manigances de
pays étrangers
mais qu'est ce que vous allez chercher
ses boys 1 non mais c'est déjà ne
reproche à leroy de cette mise à lier on
voit la population estime que c'est
anormal
ridicule et été placé ses deux trouve
anormal mais ce serait plutôt d'avoir le
tournoi toi oui non mais enfin que
peloton prochain au fait d'avoir la peau
blanche je me regarde
bah objectivement je vois pas d'abord
ils trouvent sale laide et ben sont pas
regardées qui disent que la chair pas
dégage une odeur un fade
ah bin là sans rien moi qu'est ce qu'ils
disent est on arrive enfin qu'est ce que
tu voulais qu'ils disent c'est bien
embêté bah oui mais cherchait pas alors
expliqué mais l'expliqué quoi j'étais
blanche il ne voyait bien mais pas ce
sont des abrutis tenait enfin tout ça au
départ c'est de votre faute quoi
parfaitement ses ventes mais fait
blanche mais pas faire noir non pour
tout le monde
alors là ce que nos petites filles mais
vraiment ton père et moi on pouvait pas
prévoir a pu même avec la meilleure
volonté on n'aurait pas bien ton assez
reproché son mariage parce que outre la
couleur de ma peau
j'étais son unique épouse quoi ils en
ont plusieurs
ah bien sûr alors un chauffard a été mis
en demeure de répudier un coup d'état a
été fomentée par mon plus jeune
beau-frère 13 ans et demi peut péter
déchaînés alors on est obligé de
s'enfuir
on a franchi la frontière est apte à un
cargo jusqu'à d'accord l'avion pour la
france et me voilà c'est fini ça du tout
évidemment ce progrès un support
croyable qui peut voir comme préjugés
ces gens là
à côté de nous beauvais ils font pas
t'endormir quoi enfin tu vas faire jouer
des relations pas si le ministre des
affaires étrangères valentin brown
connaît plus depuis que je suis parti
oui mais c'est plus le même mais alors
là si le président de la république il
n'a pas changé
tu m'as dit que vous aviez beaucoup
sympathisé quantités reçues même quitte
à passer avec laurent réa mais qu'est ce
que tu veux qu'il fasse c'est pas lui
qui rendra ma peau noire ni seuls deux
aux fleurs blanches et ben voilà donc je
dis draft on te regarde d'un drôle
d'oeil chez les blancs on veut pas de
toi chez les noix au nom des mariages
pareil c'est la bouteille à langres
tricot dans le mariage c'est l'amour
ouais en attendant moi j'ai l'air fin
avec médium
9 son patron bonsoir monsieur boeuf
josiane déjà de retour
vous voyez alors heureuse c'est amusant
d'être reine ou amusants n'ont pas tous
les jours c'est toi ça t'amuse d'être
mécanicien à bas encore assez oui
surtout maintenant c'est moi qui mets de
la faire si ça marche fort je suis très
contente pour toi mon mollet qui sauve
qui a vraiment s'il était bon à rien
j'en suis revenu on voit à un voyage
officiel au plaisir
or tout ce que je peux dire c'est que
j'ai pas pris un aller retour à quoi ça
a mal tourné
ah oui plutôt je peux même dire que j'ai
eu chaud mais tu n'as pas perdu sa
couronne bah c'est mon petit lucien il
en est souvent ainsi des rois et des
reines pas vous moi ça n'a pas été long
mais alors mais qu'est ce que tu vas
faire les bureaux de place non la
sténose oublie pas du jour au lendemain
pour envoyer à google
eh bien nous nous rendrons de voyage de
noces nous ici et moi comprenons vous ne
saviez pas ah non mais comment tu n'as
pas reçu le faire partir ça a été un
coup de foudre vous savez josiane
vraiment on s'est beaucoup vu avec
d'huguette après ton départ et puis un
jour on s'est décidé toutes mes
félicitations et mes voeux de bonheur
inutile de vous dire que je ne travaille
plus j'ai quitté le chapelet
est ce que c'est que cette connerie
impossible de raconter soir face à
monsieur boeuf
bonsoir madame brefs et peu de courrier
pour moi non merci bonsoir monsieur
boeuf on se remet d'un boeuf
c'est même le jour dans les nues elle
n'a même pas reconnu ce qui pourra venir
nous voir josiane enfin je ne sais pas
si c'est une invitation très
protocolaire bon je m'accepte quand même
ma chaire huguette vous verrez ma
cuisine j'ai une installation derniers
modèles
ça j'en suis fier de ma cuisine
lucien et s'est rien refusé mois va en
effet je vois et vous avez vu mon sac en
croco et ma bague superbe les garder
pour faire la vaisselle
[Musique]
c'est ma femme de ménage une femme de
ménage
décidément vous avez tout un jeu propre
à petit cependant pas s'impatienter
à très bientôt j'espère et surtout
josiane ne vous laissez pas abattre
ça ne sert à rien sinon j'avais un
josien
pardon excusez
mais voilà j'arrive gay
oh
cela crée là
une étude a entendu cette poudreuse
je pouvais pas m'empêcher de penser que
le manteau de fourrure leur sac en croco
et la cuisine dernier modèle c'est toi
qui aurait pu les avoir bon sac en croco
et la cuisine dernier modèle tout le
monde peut les avoir tout le monde
mais quoi toi fort j'ai eu davantage
midi dans maman t'as vu les renard
d'huguette c'est du lapin ou deux si
bien tout doit pas josiane pts soutenu
gilles cette façon répond telesur
galicien et huguette saint cloud pour
libre un jour ou l'autre il avait appris
mes romans
on reste à la hauteur à la hauteur de
quilles à hauteur de quoi la perte d'un
drone objets plus beau mon pote m'a tout
de suite pris en grippe
comme marion toile est bon enfant
je ne sais pas de sa faute à cette
pauvre petit vallon coûte papa j'étais
là tranquille en famille
j'avais déjà presque tout oublié moulié
oublier la doit surtout d'oublier les
papillons pas de raison qu'ils attendent
dans la rue là ils n'ont pas oublié
ils réclament la reine josiane ils
veulent la voir la reine josiane iata
leur dire qu'elle n'existe pas c'est une
jolie mentalité dans tous les cantons
marie leurs oiseaux phare il n'a pas
abdiqué lui 1 et ont beau frère n'est
qu'un vulgaire usurpateur je pense que
j'ai appris à danser la valse attend un
peu qu'on se retrouve sylvain nous n'en
sommes pas là tu dois préparer son fils
à recevoir comme héritage quel héritage
fait nous sommes bombardés
josiane tu as des devoirs envers cet
enfant qui ne sont pas ceux d'une mère
ordinaire car cet enfant n'est pas comme
les autres il ne sera jamais comme les
autres offices et toi non plus tu n'es
pas comme les autres et tu ne peux pas
redevenir une fille comme les autres
évidemment mais d'un autre côté mais
quand on met rêve madame c'est pour la
vie ici je prends le métro c'est quand
même une belle étoile non si tu y crois
vraiment tous les autres droits au
tunnel bien dit que ton mari avait les
fidèles là bas on adorait avant mon
arrivée et là alors c'est parfait il ne
prend pas compte bien y amener des
agitateurs dans presque tous les pistes
route kanza c'est comme ça qu'on fait
les révolutions et qui n effraie si
longtemps du jeu mais connais tu penses
dans notre beauté du mcg a dit ayant des
ressortissants du tango à paris
oui trois bombes appartiennent étudiants
puis un autre qui semble café en costume
dans un grand restaurant
oui et alors demain tu te mets en
rapport avec eux tu les rallier à sa
cause de ça fera boule de neige oh et
puis si josiane tout l'immeuble est pour
toi tout le quartier pour toi non
assouan prince héritier j'ai une cette
nation n'aurait plus mais n'ont montré à
tous que dans l'adversité de malheur je
peux quand même être une reine pour vous
ou vient enfin je te retrouve mort une
vraie bonne place pour peut-être parce
que moi aussi ma langue romane humaniste
qu'est ce que vous leur avez encore fait
à vos américains pour qu'ils vous mettre
à la porte ils m'ont pas mis à la porte
il rentre en amérique moi qui me
plaisait tant chez sud alors il va
falloir que je veux chercher notre place
toutefois je vais tomber encore les
prends ça c'était miteux s'appelle pas
mais quand ils vous donnent des ordres
on est bien obligé de les comprendre
encordées vraiment gentils chez maman à
dijon en attendant mon divorce et
jonathan a bondi voulez vous êtes madame
d'honneur oui mais aux embouts mais vous
y êtes madame raymonde il dans cette
loge vous foulez le sol du tango du
symbole libre possible au nez quand
madame bof c'est la première fois que
des pierres étrangers j'ai en exil comme
la plupart de mes collègues on peut pas
avoir les jurés ont sonné plein coeur -
les rênes pour les barques
le chambellan le grand chambellan nous
faut un grand chambellan maman appelle
moi monsieur raymond dit pourquoi pas
rumeur plutôt dans votre mari a beaucoup
plus le physique de l'emploi
c'est vrai qu'il peut plus distinguer et
moi alors 2e dan d'honneur 2e seulement
combien d'une paire et de leurs par quoi
on lui donne un titre et réclame de
l'argent part de ce marché pas vous
moquez pas d'aplomb madame avis cet
honneur est foutu je ne tiendrais
vraiment ma cour que le dimanche après
midi
le reste du temps vous pourrez faire des
ménages ah bon bon ben alors je veux
bien josiane m'ajuster majesté
tu es la germaine mais jamais je ne te
parle pas et la reine qui t'a fait
appeler monsieur raimondi voulez vous
être mon grand chambellan moi je veux
bien tout ce qu'on veut pourvu que ma
germaine normande faire le dîner bon ben
je me dévoue aux services de la reine
tient bon un grand chambellan de ta mère
la cour et constituer enfin grosso modo
il nous faudra réunir au gouvernement et
nous faire représenter aux nations unies
un moment face à celle affaires du roi
et la voilà repartie
qu'est ce que tu as fait la cheville de
l'histoire madame beurre avec les grands
trash
vous savez lucien réfléchir à une
situation pour votre mari oui c'est pas
brillant mais là c'est lorsqu'il faut
manger
oui j'aurais besoin d'un gars pour laver
les voitures marie céline jay arrive pas
tout seul nous déclarons la sécurité
sociale et si vous avez besoin d'une
robe chose la petite josiane ou d'une
paire de chaussures
n'hésitez pas à me le dire elle a un
coeur d'or vo c'est la moindre des
choses quand on a des amis dans le
pétrin il se peut que ça ferraille un
jour laver les voitures dans votre
garage
il se peut que vous ne voyaient en lui
qu'un pauvre type chassé de son pays
mais je vous rappelle que vous allez
vous trouver en présence d'une personne
royale et qu'en ces lieux vous devez
toujours le traiter comme tel laissez le
parler pas de questions appelait le
cidre ou majesté
c'est sans doute le roi met en place
mon grand chambellan par les ratons ses
toiles grand chambellan
ouvrez la porte est annoncée ouvre la
porte et annonce
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'on veut nous la
révérence sa majesté le roi enfin non
moi
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous et de messieurs barillet et grédy
le décor et de roger à
[Applaudissements]
les costumes de jacqueline cormier
la mise en scène de jacques crs
pierre lefebvre
[Applaudissements]
l'imsa redonnèrent
aussi ce jeu faux
françoise angèle
robert naud béal
la pyrale 1
jacky crs
laurence blot
gilbert d'autres
filippini pascal
et maison
rien de bien fontanel
jacques morel
[Musique]